deux femmes engagées auprès des enfants
pour deux espaces familiaux de
guyancourt d'un côté madeleine brès
premier docteur en médecine devenu
pédiatre de l'autre l'artiste joséphine
baker mère de douze enfants adoptés de
nom donné au nouveau lieu d'accueil
enfants parents et relais d'assistants
maternels des espaces inauguré samedi 6
avril avec la présence de trois enfants
de joséphine baker
moi je suis très fier ma famille est
aussi que l'on pense à célébrer ou
honorer le nom de ma mère dans des lieux
consacré à l'enfance et aussi à la
tolérance
ces deux espaces dédiés à la petite
enfance et à la parentalité viennent
compléter l'offre de services de la
commune dans ces domaines cela permet
aussi d'avoir des échanges entre parents
et parfois pour sa part ans c'est
l'occasion de sortir un petit peu
d'isolement quand ils sont un peu seuls
chez eux notamment quand les enfants
sont pas encore nés et scolarisés ou
alors dans une structure telle que la
crèche pour l'europe c'est elles savent
et ils demandés explique maternelle
puisque on a une centaine d'assistantes
maternelles sur la ville aujourd'hui ce
sont est démuni pour que leurs enfants
puissent avoir un lien un échange avec
d'autres assistantes maternelles la
caisse d'allocations familiales a
contribué à ce projet notamment avec un
investissement de 109 mille euros c'est
évident qu'on ne peut pas laisser les
parents seuls dans cette grande tâche
parce qu'on n'est pas pavant on le
devient avant toute chose ces deux
nouveaux services vont fonctionner en
alternance sur le même site